[音楽]
me
今日は回収ギター
グリーン掴もうしません
私はこの子が家で8年間
自給自足循環型の暮らしをつくってきました
初めは不コップ1本から会沢会合を始めそして
家づくりを始めました
代謝もう秘密基地を作ろうっていうのにで作り始めたんですけどね
こんな家で戦最初小屋から作ったんですけれども
なぜこういう暮らしを作ろうかっていうキー加減があったのは2011年3月11日
東北の東日本大震災ですね
皆さんもご存知の通り
電気ガスシードが止まって家が崩れたり
そして道路がなくなったりっていう人に大変な災害でした
私もそこでボランティアに生かしていただいて
大変な状況を目の当たりにしました
ちょうどその時に私の師匠からメッセージがきました
自分がもしすべてのライフラインが止まった時
電気ガス水道が止まったときに同国か
同プラスかということです
そういう投げかけをもらいました
皆さんは一度こういうことを考えたことありますか
電気ガス水道が止まってライフラインが止まった時
何かこうしておこうだとか何か実践されてる方も知らしたから
またいらっしゃったらの後でねえ私のブースの方でシェアする時間がありますので是非
その時にシェアしていただけたらありがたい
今はこんなページの夜中でワンタッチでいろいろ
ご飯がだけたりお湯が沸いたりそしてすぐ近くに何でもそれをコンビニがあったりと
いう便利な暮らしになっています
でもいざ災害になった時にはこの暮らしっていうのは本当に弱くで56便
何事かえないことが多くなるということに実感しました
そこで私は最下位に付くらしい
そして電気ガス水道が止まっても生きていける暮らしっていうのを本気で作ろうと思い
ました
まずはやっぱり水が必要ですよねっ
水は超えて山や川に行けばいざいますね
その他いいですね雨水タンクというのが1匹
やって屋根オフの中の上に降ってきた雨を
という伝ってタイプの中に奄美の食べば
その中には伏見を引いたらしいから三島簡単なろ過システムができるんですね
ある程度きれいな水が出ます
あと a なんですね
日が必要な気くんこれは薪ストーブですね
薪ストーブではお湯が沸かせたりご飯がだけたりだとか
そして暖かさ負担を取ることができます
ココロもカラダも傍目てくれますね
休みの日には止めに入って薪を調達します
間伐材だとかば綿棒今は木がたくさん
タオル2時するんですけれどもなんかカメラ c
巻あたかもたくさんあるんですけども実は山に行かなくても近くの工務店だとかで
飯を作ってる工務店だとかでしたら昨日肌があるんですね
少し余った木が沢山捨てられています
それも巻として十分使えます
そして木造住宅の潰している現場に行けば今度その木造の梁や柱が十分
巻になるんですね
事前に40センチくらいに切ってストックしておいたらこれも薪になります
こうやって自分のアイディア次第自分の労力次第でエネルギーがタダでいただきていっ
ちゃうんですね
本当に便利です
そしてこういった
ラケットスタートというのもあります
これはペール缶を2つ繋げているんですけれどもこのペール缶簿
ガソリンスタンドに行くと a
毎日毎日粉の入った缶カーが出てくるんですけども
ラケットストーブこの2つつなげたの中には断熱材とそれと
破産へ
炎髪ですね援竜が入ればいい
そして左側の口のところで割り箸たとか
小枝を燃やすと天板の上でお湯が沸かしたり炒め物ができる
それぐらいまでの優れものなんですねすごい各火力が増えます
これはだいたいコスト的には5千円から6千円くらいで自分たちで作れます
1時間あれば作れる感じですね
これは最近は地域の公民館だとかで
災害グッズとして作られたり置いてあったりそれは本当に優れものでいます
あとお風呂を渡すこの薪ボイラーって言うんですけど
エコキュートのような缶君これがプリンタぐらいの短期でへ
脇でお湯を沸かしますこれも80度から90度ぐらいまで子どもたちで一緒には化し
たりしています
そして後もう一つ屋根の上に太陽のピョン席
石地で入りましたね田舎のほうで
屋根の上にこれも600リッターほどタンクのせて太陽の熱をそのまま暖かくして寝ず
にしてお湯にできるシステムです
これ本当にシンプルで素晴らしいと思いますもっともっと普及すればいいなと思ってい
ます
この屋根の上に600リンターの水があるということは常に家の上には600リッター
が見ずらいます
よく寝災害対策でををフローやいつも800ようにっていうことも言われますけども
これは屋根の上に常に600行ったのですがある
確保されているっていう便利ですね
あとやっぱり皆さん元気に一票ですよね
こういった電機
1本でちょっと見えないんですけどもみなさんのご家庭にもあるかと思いますけれども
太陽光発電のソーラーパネルが置かれている方もたくさんあるかと思います
一般の家庭に上げられている大体のシステムは売電方式といって自分の家の屋根で作ら
れた
勉強ですね一度電柱電線を伝ってそして電力会社の方にわたっていきますそして使う
ときにまた
電柱電線を使って家に送られてくるんですけども
この時に大きなそうだ
いますというのはあって電気が半分くらい
汚したの失われていくんですね
それももったいないです
あと電柱電線が何か地震災害の時に倒れた場合はそれが使えませんよね
私が提案したのは鹿バッテリーの蓄電型の太陽光パネルがあるんです
まだまだ小さいシステムからなんですけれどもこういった電機とか
そして携帯電話を充電するには十分できるかと思います
そうやって日々実したくらしいに向けて電気ガス水道が止まっても生きていけるらしい
っていうのを楽しみながら日々挑戦して何かお得なものはないかとかあと何か再利用
できるものはないかということで毎日電波を張って家づくりをしていました
1件目は小さな小屋
そして思えを作ったんですけども2件目
薪ストーブのショールームをつくってそしてなんと3件目
作っちゃいました
こういう音大きいこれは古民家解体を自分たちでしてきてそして
移築して作ったゲストハウスになってます
自分たちの循環型の暮らしっていうのいろんな都会の人にも体験して欲しいということ
で下スタートを作ったんですけれどもこの時にはやっぱりいろんな許認可を得るのが
大変だったりだとか
そして期限が止められてたりだとかそして食べたばこの冬には大雪に見舞われて
とうとう私の体も大きな止めを起こし
タフか買い込んじゃったんですね
一つのやめが喘息発作というのが出てしまって
本当に息をするのも苦しくてそしてトイレ行ったり階段上がるというのも本当に苦しい
苦しい毎日でした
そして私の生活スタイルは自然派志向ということで売っていたので私は薬を飲むという
選択をせずにですね
自然ショップ市電料理幼女
シェイ氏で-8
自然療法で治そうということを固く思っていました
食事養生したいんだとか温熱療法
そして音さ両方だとかいろんな薬をに二里に頼らないそういう治療方法を自分で選んで
ました
でもなかなか良くならなくて私はその時
体重が今から12キロも減っちゃったんですね
そして心も体も少し弱ってしまった時に私の友達のドクター
体力が戻るまで少し
ゆるい薬を飲んでみてはどうかというアドバイスを受けました
そして私はかたくなに2両拒んでいたんですけども体力も限界が来ていたので少しと尻
を飲みました
そうするとどんどんどんどん行きができるようになって元気になって今日のように便皆
さんの前で元気に登壇できたり階段もスイスイ上がれるようになっちゃいました
この時に気づいたんですね
私はすごい独りよがりだったんだなっていうこと
あと保湿して考えが良い本当に固まっていたんだなということを築きました
自分の目指していた事実していた暮らしっていう言葉をすごい
自分の中で勘違いしてました
他のものに頼ったりしない
自分自身が強く生きることが大切だということが事実という言葉は私は hey
なんか勘違いしてました
この a
暮らしを作ったりとか病気病をきっかけですね
私は自立した行くらしいというのを本当はいろんな方法や手段を持ったり
そしてたくさんのいろんな木をしっかり元ということで安全な暮らしだとか
そして
安心した人生豊かな人生が作れるんじゃないかって思いました
振り返ってみれば私も家づくり小野山よってからですね
たくさんの人に助けられたり支えられたり
そしていろんな友達からアドバイスを受けたり
いっぱいしました
その中でもええわたちのアドバイス
受けながらもたくさんの失敗もしました
失敗をしてはもう一度どんな方法があるかということを探して再度チャレンジしたりと
かいろんなことにチャレンジしました
一つの既製品に頼るんじゃなくて自分で何か色々作ってみる
まず来て日
このテックスもそうだと思います
みんなで海のプロシミを体験しながら
そしてみんなで作り上げた時の喜び感動
らしいですよね
そしてこの指の苦しみを乗り越える時に
みんなでアイデアを出し合ったりそして助け合ったり
支え合ったりそしてお互いが共存協定していくことが大切
そして
会社をすることが大切なんて伺う地図きました
この絵は私の生きる手段の一つとしてですね
職業で筆文字メッセージお寺でパフォーマンスで書いた時の性なんですけども
感謝を忘れずにということいつも思っています
今日はあともうひとつの私の生きる手段の職業
もう一つ知らんですね沖縄の半身を使ってですね
a まといたバンドの
歌で宝物という歌を歌いたいと思います
この歌は一つ一人と自然がつながる大切さを歌った歌になります
ぜひ今日はね一発目で退場ちょっと明るくしてい
はいです
沖縄三線税
入った
[音楽]
みんなで胸を張って会うこと
何も恥ずかしくないと思いますプライドなんて気にせずにっっ一つ人のつながりそして
ひょっと事前のつながり
今日は母の日ですね
私も母が来ていてちょっと前いじめ感謝を伝えるのは凄いてれるんですけれどもこのま
ざーす
またザレイプですね今日は滋賀県の琵琶湖京都にも感謝して反射奪ったとしても唱え
たいと思います
タイムか塾とまーちゃんの歌でに宝物です
ああああああ
ああああああああ
ます
はっはーっ
r
あった
はぁ
ん
8頭はなぜ
[音楽]
1 r
den o 3がー
あからな noooooo
ああああああああ
大磯らー
アーリー ana
3例は図3位なんなら
タッカー卵黄あの方へ
air
43 nana ran ちゃん22 a
か
1 a
いやああああああっはぁっ
ana
[音楽]
者に代位
ana
a
にゃーんっあっ
[音楽]
re
あっんっ
[音楽]
んじゃサマーヌー
サンレイは皆んなら
100うん飯盒あのー4 r
なラフ12回位
[音楽]
管理だけよーったんだーー
campy
んだんだねーもうこの顔
青いシートだ
[音楽]
入ったダウンに懸命
なーん
わーい
うわぁ
[音楽]
皆さんも一緒だろあああああ
んだーらーらららーらんららららいあーわー
なーらーららーんランド恥ずかしいから口に持った
はぁー
んならならーラダー氏
はぁ
まんだ bahram アーランらんざんんなおちゃんありがとうございます